i love comparing myself to other people  i think it's healthy i think it's  inspiring i think it can get you  way outside your comfort zone i think it  can show you what's possible i think  most people can't handle comparing  themselves to others because they use it  as a kick down because when you see  somebody else having success you feel  like this person's so far ahead this  person has done so much this person did  way more than me at a way younger age  there's no way i can ever keep up  the difference is you have to learn how  to use it use the comparison to kick  yourself forward instead of kicking  yourself down  most of the world compares themselves to  other people to keep themselves down to  feel not good enough to feel less than  they feel like you don't belong instead  of using it as inspiration to move  forward to say this is what's possible